welcome to e380 this is uh uh for uh
June the 7th 2023 in any case uh the
other day as I was planning what we were
going to do today
it occurred to me that we'd been
spending a lot of time on the uh the
current software issues of the day the
generative Ai and machine learning and
we really had been neglecting the thing
that makes it really work that is uh the
hard work
and
um not only that
just about the same time that I was
beginning to do this uh Nvidia
crossed a magical marker it became the
first trillion dollar company in the
computer industry and
um that was quite exciting and it sort
of suggested that the best thing to do
was to get our
uh
our class together and
[Music]
um
that's what has happened
um any case our speakers from Nvidia and
uh he can introduce himself Jack you're
on
so hello everybody
um I guess I've already introduced
jacket
um and I'm going to talk I've been asked
to talk to you about nvidia's Hopper GPU
um and the design did and and how we
went about designing it
um
let's see so today I'm going to cover
just an overview of the hopper 100 GPU
we're going to talk a little bit about
the hierarchy and asynchrony are key to
his performance and now Hopper took
advantage of these uh components to
accelerate them
describe how Hopper accelerates deep
learning
um and then I'm going to finish up with
a brief description about the h100 GPU
is used in system to scale its
performance
feel free to interrupt and ask questions
as we're going along and I'll see if I
can answer them
as best I can
uh so let's start with the overview
um Hopper is built on tsmc custom
important animator process contains over
80 billion transistors which makes it
the world's most advanced modeling chip
contains 132 SMS each delivering twice
the performance of our previous
generation a100 SMS and includes
multiple new features
um includes a new memory system
featuring hbm3 a larger L2 cache so
they're a much higher memory bandwidth
and previous generation
it also supports multi-gpu super pod and
file designs a variety and added a
variety of new system architecture
features including the fourth generation
Envy link and new ambient Network second
generation multi-instance GPU technology
as well as new accelerated confidential
Computing Sports which is a secured
accelerated compute
um
so diving into the SM processor core
itself uh you know Hoppers made many
improvements to the core it features a
twice a 2X clock for clock Improvement
on traditional fp32 and fp64 throughput
it supports a 256 kilobytes of unified
L1 and shared memory storage which is 33
more than our previous generation a100
contains the new fourth generation
tensor core that is 2x faster and
specifically more efficient
Hopper also introduced a new Dynamic
instruction set for dynamic programming
called DPX it provides Advanced Opera
infusion for inner loop and many dynamic
programming algorithms it has tensor
memory accelerator proficient
asynchronous data movements and
multi-dimensional tensor data
and finally we added a new level of
hierarchy between Cuda and thread
through the cudaharak you have thread
blocks and grids called the thread block
clusters and threadblock clusters will
enable us applications take advantage of
locality additional locality that the
GPU provides to dramatically improve the
efficiency of many algorithms
um upper has five hbm3 sites with a
total memory capacity of 80 gigabytes
the memory system has been designed to
maximize notches the peak bandwidth but
delivered bandwidth achieve this it
features improvements about the memory
memory as well as gpu's memory
controllers which are optimized run at
dramatically increased DRM frequencies
and redesigned to include twice as
memory memory channels for HP on site to
maintain the same high efficiency
despite the increase in frequency
as a result we can achieve three
terabytes per second of memory bandwidth
uh 2x the throughput of our previous
generation a100
um and a hopper rh2 we made several
improvements to our Mig technology
um uh it provides three times more
compute capacity per make than a 100 and
roughly twice more memory bandwidth curb
make
we added dedicate image and video
decoder engines to our GPU instance
these are very important for our AI
interesting customers who do a lot of
image and video processing it's not just
about the AI but a lot about the image
processing video processing you need to
do in order to to do the AI
um we combined our Mick technology with
confidence computer technology for
secure execution here The Trusted
environment encapsulates one
confidential VM running on the CPU with
a MIG instance running on the GPU we
took advantage of the physical isolation
of the units of the make already provide
the hardware Dyno Provide Plus we added
a hardware firewall to prevent any
unauthorized access to memory from
outside the trusted execution
environment including from other Mig
instances on the same GPU
uh PCI interface we have Sr Sr iov which
stands for single root i o
virtualization it virtualizes all the
registers needed to control and program
each GPU instance
all transfers on pcie are encrypted each
GPU has its own set of keys so there's
no data sharing between VMS or between
GPU instances
and by combining the Mig and confidence
Computing h100 has the world's first
multi-tenant Native confidential
Computing platform using a single GPU
and it's just kind of a just a diagram a
table of where you can see the
performance for our main for key
mainstream HPC AI models including many
vision and neural networks or smaller
language models
and you can see that we can develop
anywhere from two to three times
performance or previous generation where
we both use infiniband to connect the
the gpus
um if you start looking at adding NB
link to it not using Infinity band but
using the MV link Network interconnect
it actually enables more efficient
scaling across multiple gpus
accelerating the nodes and providing a
major boost performance across HPC and
aai applications
um with this with using every link
instead Infinity Band by an additional
two to three x performance recruitment
for hvc and AI training
um now I'm going to dive into the
details there's some of the new features
for Hopper
uh but first i'm going to talk over some
key principles performance and describe
the improvements and features that
Hopper has made to take advantage of
those principles uh to improve
efficiency and performance
so there here are two key principles for
achieving high performance repairable
programs one key principle is data
locality by moving and keeping the data
program data as close as possible
execution units the programmer can
exploit the performance that comes from
having lower latency and higher
bandwidth access to local data
another key principle is asynchronous
execution this means finding and
allowing independent tasks and data
movement to overlap as much as possible
the goal keeping all the units fully
utilized and avoiding serialization
so let's look at closer at data locality
and Cooperative execution
so locality can occur either spatially
or temporally with spatial locality data
and parallel execution of a spatial
relationship which we thought of compute
and data being co-located
one example of a computation using data
data space spatial spatial data locality
is spatial Halo overlap as shown in in
the figure
a common a computation operates not only
on the data that's Direct in its
rectilinear dial but also shares data
with the computations operating on
adjacent tiles
another example is where computation has
a spatial sharing is one or one
dimension has to be combined with data
in a different dimension which is not
shown in the figure but is also a common
pattern
with temporal locality data and parallel
execution have a temporal relationship
which can be more thought of compute
passing over the data data stays the one
location and compute kind of passes over
it an example showing the figure first
one kernel process of the data in memory
and then another person kernel process
daily memory
so let's review first the spatial
locality that current nvida gpus before
h100 supported
um encoder locality can be expressed as
a grid of execution and a grid is mapped
onto the GPU Hardware hierarchy
computational GPU takes advantages
stores local to that GPU in case of
Hopper that's 50 megabytes of L2 cache
and 80 gigabytes of hbm3 memory
the next little locality can be
expressed is a thread block which is
mapped onto the SM Hardware hierarchy
here computation can take advantage of
256 kilobytes of SM localized storage
and the L1 data cache plus shared
parameter
the smallest level of locality you can
express in in Cuda is threads these are
mapped to Hardware thread lanes and here
the computation X advantage of thread
local register file storage which is a
one kilobyte per thread and this
translates to six of our kilobytes per s
on partition and 250 kilobytes per SM of
thread uh register file storage
the way that work is mapped onto the
hardware is being the grid level work
and breaking into fragments of work and
assigning them to the thread block
the figure Sharon has broken up as
two-dimensional grid but Cuda hardware
and the Cuda and the Harvard supports
three-dimensional mappings as well
programmers use whatever the mapping
works best for them they don't Harvard
doesn't dictate what the mapping needs
to be
independent blocks each work on their
own fragment of the problem within the
blocks there are multiple threads that
cooperatively execute on the fragment of
a work they assigned to that block
so this three levels of GP hierarchy is
this this and screw first introduced and
as Naval parallel programs take
advantage of locality exists in their
algorithms and and take advantage of the
hardware locality that existed that
we've been mapped onto
um the challenge is that gpus have
scaled since then since student
introduced by order of magnitude now
here I'm showing the Nvidia Kepler GPU
which introduced 10 years ago and had 15
SMS
here's the Nvidia Hopper GPU today it
has 132 SMS we want to order magnitude
increase until in 10 years
if you look at it the entire Kepler GPU
could fit in the corner of of one hopper
GPU right just a small corner of what
the Opera needs to be the capital GPU is
roughly the same size as a hopper GPC
level of hierarchy that we have in the
hardware
to take advantage of the solution and
locality h100 has an additional level of
Park to kudo the thread block cluster
here the conversation take advantage of
the GPS GPC Hardware hierarchy that has
and the 256 kilobytes of localized
storage in ESL that sounds within
cluster can communicate directly to each
other through an SM to SM Network
and Cuda a thread block cluster is just
a big is a block full of thread blocks
now you can think of it as thread blocks
on steroids Fair blocks and cluster no
longer need to be mapped to to be
executing independently like threads in
a block blocks and a cluster can
cooperatively execute on their fragment
of the problem they can they can
exchange data they can work they can
synchronize themselves they don't have
to operate independently
this enabled us to Target look like
subset of the grid enabling more
opportunities for programmability and
for performance
clusters collected up to 16 blocks each
block is guaranteed to be on separate SM
and is guaranteed to be running at the
same time
by running the guarantee running at the
same time then they can guarantee to be
cooperating and exchanging data and
working together on whatever the problem
sets that they need to be they do not
need to be running independently
um you can have a lot more threads and
GPU xq resources all Cooperative working
essentially on the same problem s you
annotate the kernel with a cluster size
and dimension and just like blocks
Busters conventions could be one two or
three dimensional programmers use
whatever bit fits their algorithm to
what's being mapped
or the hopper Harbor itself architecture
provides clusters with a direct SM to SM
communication Network and using this
network one thread block can directly
access the shared memory of another
threadwall axes are done through a
distributed share memory models uh laid
out as a partition global address space
all memory operations supported and
reload stores Atomic synchronization
operations
the communication Network also
accelerates synchronization and data
change threads and thread blocks in a
cluster can directly synchronize each
other through barriers and distributes
their memory it also supports
asynchronous dma operations between the
thread blocks themselves
now let's move away from spatial
locality and talk about temporal locale
one form of temper locality that is
sporting existing Nvidia gpus is
dependent grid launch executing on data
L2 and hpm3 memory
the figure is the example of a fast
Fourier transform workflow
and is the transfer transform there are
multiple competitions that's the need to
perform the transform each with a
different Radix
here the data is moved into hbi memory
local to GPU from there each step is
performed by reading the data from the
local memory doing the computation and
Ryan resides back to local memories it's
available to the next step
limitations of this is that each step
must be a different kernel in the Cuda
program model and launched as the Radix
algorithm for each step requires a
different configuration of the SM
that means that between each step any
data stored in the SM must be first
flushed back to HPM memory and then read
back in for the next step
to prove the efficiency of temporal
locality we added a new capability
threadblock reconfiguration going back
to Ft example you can see how this works
there's a single grid launch for the
entire transform at each Radix step the
SM threads and register file resources
can be reconfigured to match what's
needed for the Radix done at that step
a beginner transform data is loaded from
memory into shared memory and
distributed shared memory for the things
that plot in the concept of clusters and
each rate accepts the form without data
leaving that memory
so instead of you know the temporal
locality of execution passing over data
in L2 and hbm memory we now have
execution passing over much closer and
much more efficient SM shared memory
I also closer at another core principal
performance that we looked at
asynchronous execution and data transfer
my first review how things work in a
synchronous machine design approach
Morgan apparel computation multiple
threads of work together to form that
competition
um one way to do do this is the word
feds can work cooperatively this is
where each device is doing some
computation but I work on different
parts of the data they're seeing the
same competition but working on
different parts of the data at each
phase computation the threads will
synchronize ensure that the data they're
working on is ready for the next step of
the competition next phase of
computation on that data
another model is where threads have more
producer consumer model this is where
data is produced by one thread it's
consumed by another thread and they're
doing essentially different competitions
in different parts of a pipeline
competition
here the concern is a synchronize the
producer to ensure the data has been
produced and is ready to be consumed
in a synchronous machine approach all
threads must arrive and wait at the
barium so all of the threads have also
arrived at the barrier the effect that
they're running kind of a lock step
manner this leads to an efficiency where
threads and execution resources are idle
waiting for the barrier to clear
let's see how things work with an
asynchronous machine design approach
here synchronization split there is an
arrive
there's rise barrier and then there's a
weight at that bear when threads are
cooperatively executing all threads
continue to arrive and wave the barrier
however between the arrive and the
weight each leg can schedule thread
independent work so instead of being
idle waiting for the threads to arrive
each time can we do busy doing this for
work and you can hide the the cost and
synchronization
in the producer model the threads
operate in a decoupled manner after the
producer first produces the first batch
of data it arrives and immediately
starts producing the second batch of it
doesn't have to wait the consumer the
data it needs is available it merely
starts to consume the data without
waiting or any unnecessary
synchronization
as you can see the any an asynchronous
design approach can lead to much more
efficient parallel execution
before I dive into details of Hopper
Improvement I'm going to start with the
view of the asynchronous bearers that
were available on A1 objects we already
add the concept and the ability to do
async as far as an a100 or previous
generation
um consider again the example where a
set of threads are Cooperative executing
a set of data as shown on the right a100
is async is very split this
synchronization into two steps first the
thread signals arrive or they're down
produced in proportion of the shared
data and this arrives now blocking so
the threads are free to execute other
independent work eventually the thread
needs to the the needs the data produced
by all other thread at this point it
does a weight which blocks until every
thread is actually sitting on their
arrive
and let's turn before the advanced
asynchronous barriers that allow the
threads to derive to execute our
independent work instead of just waiting
and spinning waiting for the threats to
happen
um new for each one on disability for
the waiting threads to sleep while our
threads arrive on previous chips the
weighing threads have to spin to go
through a spin loop on the barrier
object and shared memory taking up
execution resourcing and added latency
now we've accelerated that sort of
process where they can go to sleep
um and they don't take extra resources
just uh spinning on on things they just
wait until the barrier resolved and they
immediately start executing again
it's also new for Hopper is a new form
of a barrier we call the asynchronous
transaction barrier today's English
transaction here is also slip Barrel but
instead of just counting threat arrivals
it also counts memory transactions
themselves
there are new commands for writing
memory that passes both data to written
plus the barrier update in effect the
barrier can be figured to track not only
threads but also also asynchronous
memory transactions as well
the transaction variable block threads
at the weight command so all producer
threads have arrived in all asynchronous
memory transactions have completed
now this bear is very powerful new
primitive and it works great for
asynchronous memory copies or data
exchanges
so let's look how the new barrier
support combined with thread with block
thread block clusters improve the block
to block data Exchange
unless you see how block the block data
exchange is done on on older Nvidia gpus
data exchange through Global memory
using the barrier storage the two thread
blocks one wanted to communicate
um two sons need to communicate each
other they had to go through Global
memory and synchronize the Google memory
the sequence for the producer is they
write the data they do a memory barrier
they write the barrier flag the sequence
of consumers they pull the flag
determine the barrier is cleared and
then they read the data
to perform a data exchange requires
three to four round trips through Global
memory which is fairly very efficient
from a latency perspective
on the right you see how things are done
in Hopper you see the producer stores
data directly in the consumer's shared
memory while updating the bearer that's
also in the consumer shared memory
this enables a minimum latency data
exchange a one-way trip from the
producer to Consumer and results in a 7x
latency reduction
Hopper also accelerates memory copies
using a new TMA unit the TMA unit is
able to asynctically copy do memory
copies between local and shared memory
as well as between shared memory and
shared memory between blocks in a
cluster
using the numerator transaction you can
do copies of the minimal latency
the TMA is fully asynchronous with
threat execution there's no address
generation or data mover or
synchronization management overhead
requirement on the threat from the
threads perspective it's simply it's
it's simply a fire and forget it says do
this copy and then if it's about it
doesn't have to worry about it at all
this makes for a very simplified and
efficient program model
here's an example of how the Halo data
exchange is performed on Hopper with its
new capabilities here we have a cluster
of four thread blocks each working on
different parts of the data well one
thread block needs to get Halo data to
another thread block the other thread
block writes it directly into its own
into its local shared memory updating a
local barrier indicating the data is
ready
so here the data exchange officially
done async asynchronously and with
minimal latency
there's our eyes the goal of asynx
attribution to keep all units busy on
the GPU fuel utilized allow more overlap
of computation and data movement Opera
introduces an asynchronous transaction
barrier for Atomic data moves with
synchronization and makes waiting on
barriers more efficient Opera also
introduces onto accelerator for memory
copies called the TMA unit it frees the
general purpose threads from doing
memory operations and Ash calculations
allowing the threads to instead to focus
on Independent processing of tasks and
not have to worry about data moving
themselves
you combine poppers and ruins for
locality with the asynchronous execution
data movement you can get dramatic
performance improvements
here you can see in the in this where
you the performance room is a hopper
with these new capabilities to use
taking advantage of locality and
asynchrony asynchrony provides two to
three x performance benefits on these
key algorithms
now let's look at some of the
improvements Hopper made to accelerate
deep learning and AI
at the heart of the hopper SM is a new
fourth generation tensor core it has
double throughput per SM of all the data
formats Opera tensor core has also added
a new ape floating Point format it
provides twice the throughput of fp16
and B float 16 formats as matching the
throughput of 8-bit integer
in order to keep the 10 scores fat and
keep the GPU power in check Hopper
tensor cores have also improved operand
deliverancy by 30 percent
h100 like K100 Sports sparse or
potential arithmetic arithmetic enabling
2x throughput when the data is also
sparse
this chart shows the cumulative compute
improvements going from a100 to h100
the increase in number of assets
provides a 22 increase the fourth
generation tensor core provides an
additional 2x Improvement
switching from 16-bit floating point to
the new a 8-bit floating Point format
provides another additional 2x
Improvement and finally the clock
frequency improvements provide another
30 increase I'll combine I'll provide
six at six X throughput increase over
our previous generation
let's kind of dive into the new fp8
format support in a little more detail
on left we see the exponent range of
antis Precision provided by each tensor
floating Point format
you'll note that the tensor core
supports two floating point eight eight
bit floating Point formats one provides
an extra bit of exponent range that
matches the exponent range of fp16 if
you thought of a truncated mantissa
version of fp16 much louder B float 16
is a truncated mantissa version of fp32
the other eight fp8 format trades off
one bit of range for an additional one
bit of precision
on the right you can see how the test
score process FBA uh floating Point
8-bit floating Point data the
multiplication of 8-bit floating Point
data can be accumulating to the either
fp32 or fp16
once the Matrix multiplies done various
common Network neural functions like
adding bias and applying an activation
function can move warm and the higher
fp32 or fp16 precision
the final result is then converted to
desired output format before being
stored back to memory
foreign
distribution for a variety of network
layers and a single language model you
can see that the distribution can vary
significantly some have a wider exponent
range that are best mapped to the E5 M2
fp8 format others have a narrow exponent
range require more Precision to
differentiate the value these are best
mapped to an E4 M3 FPA format
on the right you can see that during the
linear math computation
the range of the results can be outside
the fp8 representable range
by forming the Matrix multiply
accumulation in the fp16 OR fp32 formats
we're able to safely perform the
computation without any loss
but when we convert back down to the fva
format we scale the results into the FPA
representable range
so the goal is an exposition is to
intelligently manage the Precision and
maintain accuracy will still gain the
performance of smaller faster numerical
formats
statistics of the output values of each
layer of a network can be analyzed to
determine which FPA format is optimal
and what scaling factors needed when
converting to the final computation of
into that FPA format
the figure right shows training of gbt3
model and how the training error changes
over time for various layers it Compares
a training error using fp8 format using
the versus the native B float 16 format
you see that you probably can't tell but
because the lines are right on top of
each other
um the basically the the the using
training using FBA and scaling
techniques you can almost it's precisely
match the error over time of the Native
B float 16 format
on the last you see a table of the final
accuracy for a variety of networks using
fp8 versus native 16-bit format as you
can see the accuracy are nearly
identical
let's dive a bit more into the new TMA
unit I already talked about how the two
main unit efficiently performs
asynchronous copies it was designed
specifically to handle complexity of
copying and managing multi-dimensional
deep learning tensors in memory
a little iron activity addresses strides
bound checking needed for tensors up to
rank five it'll even automatically pad
out of bound values so you don't get
junk when copies go out of bounds
and you need to pad all this is done
with a fire and forget model from a
single thread single thread fires it off
it does the copy and the thread can
continue executing and once the copy is
finished the the the the asynchronous
transaction barrier will actually get
updated and then uh computation can be
done on that on that copied data
so you can see when taking all that in
how much end-to-end speed up we get on a
model like tpt3 uh with sequence like
um and you can see that we get approx
almost a 3X application speed up using
FBA versus on h100 versus using B float
and a100 and I'll experience we're done
running on a 64 gpus
now Hoppers GPU is designed with the
rest of system reminder it's not just
the GPU chip itself you need to make
sure it can integrate to a larger system
and run very well
so it has direct support for tight
integration with other such components
and ability to scale up and out
give you a brief overview of some of the
integration and scaling capabilities of
the hopper GPU and how the systems are
built
proper GPU is the h1n GPU is packaged in
a module with 94 gigabytes HPM free
memory with 3.5 terabytes per second of
bandwidth
eight of these gpus are fully connected
on a single board using the Envy link
switches providing 900 gigabytes per
second of bandwidth per GPU
here's what the board looks like when
you add in all the heatsinks i o
interfaces and other components
now here's a kind of block diagram of
that board and showing the main
components of the ggx node and how
they're connected their two CPUs help
Drive the system along with some CX-7
nics and PCI switches
all the h100 gpus are fully connected
with MB switches these MV switches are
also connected to a high bandwidth
mv-link i o ports leading out of the
node
here's all packaged together in the node
is what the box actually looks like
this node is plugged into a Quantum 2
infiniband network with 400 gigabits per
second of bandwidth per ports
and this system can scale to hundreds or
thousands of dgx notes
foreign
very efficient scaling here you see the
ndn performance for weak scaling it is
almost linear going from 32 gpus to
three over three thousand gpus
and also strong scales very well not
just B scale but Strong's failed around
it provides almost linear speed up for
Megatron going from 64 gpus to 2048 gpus
I expect to push that even Beyond 2048
as well
all right now for questions
that's it that's it in a nutshell if you
find more information in the hopper
architecture white paper any questions
amazing piece of Hardware Jack
ET as the slide says now this is many
Engineers worked on this and designed it
and built these systems so it's a
product of a lot of work for a lot of
people yeah I can't I can't take credit
for it okay and the the one thing that
that of course is always a problem for
this class of machine is some of the
advantage comes from judicious choices
in layout of data and uh
structure of the program that uses the
machine and is that now entirely in the
hands of Kudo or is it something that a
programmer needs to actually do the work
to do the partitioning
well it
we provide multiple sort of
um
abstractions right
now there are people if you want you can
program to the bare metal and handle
everything yourself right and Kudo has
that level of abstraction
um and you can program in the Cuda level
when it comes to a lot of these networks
um most of this is actually done under
our libraries and and the abstraction
that we do is we provide KU GNN and
other libraries uh other sort of
compilers and stuff that will actually
map Things efficiently so people are
doing DL networks and trying to run on
our systems they are not programming
Cuda they're programming and and uh the
more of the Python layer
um using regular sort of thing and all
our all the software and attractions and
compiler and libraries underneath that
do the the mapping for you
if I want one for my home computer
what's this going to cost me
uh which one the just the dgx box or you
want the whole you know system here
right you want you want this guy
yeah I like the big one but the small
one is easier to carry around no I'm
just looking for scale of cost here
um to tell you the truth and I'm not in
sales and marketing so I don't really
know the exact cost for these things
um I I do know that that the total cost
of ownership and and the performance per
total cost of ownership as well as as
execution uh sorry uh not just the
purchase but to run it
um is actually very good compared to
other systems and that's actually one
thing that we do when we start talking
about you know in place from how it
filters down to me doing the
architecture and it's like that is that
um you know you you kind of think I also
put for millimeters all the stuff well
you know there are the the the the cost
is not just in the chip
the cost is in the system and you need
to make sure that you build a chip that
even if it's not the great perfume like
having all the Envy link i o and all
other support
um this is why that makes the chip less
per millimeter but it makes the system
much more efficient and much more cost
effective so so you need to kind of
think about that also from Power
perspective and how you kind of manage
things
um because cost of ownership power cost
is a significant part of the cost of
ownership and you make sure that you do
work well on that even if it helps you
know hurt your per millimeter you know
you gotta think about the overall power
of the system and how you actually make
uh the overall the system more uh cost
effective
um to the people who are buying them
sounds good uh questions everybody
okay I have one person okay yeah hey I
have a I have a I have a question I'll
just read the question which somebody
put in chat okay so 11 kilowatts TDP I
guess that's must be for a constellation
of them not for a single h100
um can you tell us a bit about power and
Cooling
of the system no I'm not that familiar
with it you probably know more about it
by looking it up than I do
uh I don't do the system design I do GPU
and so um no although I'm I'm fairly
familiar with some of the trade-offs and
the concerns they have uh I'm not the
right person to quote the right Specter
like I said you probably looked up more
information than what I know maybe could
you just talk about from a GPU
standpoint like I'm certainly thermals
are like a very big concern or yeah like
what are aspects of the design which
really were influenced by
um the power Etc
well so so
the the assets and design you look at
you know the these are the gpus and you
know you had to eat things like that
there's a lot of power to get out of
there
um and part of the part of what you see
is that that from the from the board you
know the GPU
you like to have all the power in the
world he says well I can get more
performance by more power but the
challenge is that it has to fit into the
form factor in the system
um and like I said we're not we're one
component of the system and and like I
said I didn't do The Thermals and and
the the whole thing but there's a lot of
sort of feedback of of how we make sure
that we're power efficient in order to
get the most power most of most
performance of a particular power budget
and that actually influences uh probably
substantially
um and uh and I do know that you know
there are different sort of systems and
again you probably know better than I
was
you're asking these questions and
probably looked into it a lot more than
I have but there there there are sort of
things about you know air cooled versus
water cooled
um and and what different data centers
can support
um they're not all identical and you
can't plug them all the same way and so
um we start looking at the the
performance power sort of Curves
um you know you can actually get a fair
amount of efficiency by going up of the
performance power curve
um assuming the system can handle it
um so it's a lot of data centers are
moving towards something where the
individual nodes can actually take a
little more power and getting a lower
actual lower cost of ownership uh by by
writing that curve a bit better
okay
so what do you think is going to happen
next
um
now working on our next Generation stuff
um and uh you'll see that you know
eventually
um and uh
you know there's a lot of interesting
challenges
um particularly with large language
models and and the direction that that
AI is going to
um
uh as far as specifics I don't think I
can talk about specifics about what's
the the main problems we're tackling and
how we're tackling them
um but but this is not the Pinnacle of
where we can be
it's a stepping stone in between yeah
and it's uh that's an impressive piece
of hardware
but when you look at you know sort of
from a hundred thousand foot range
it's uh basically just another
collection of processors in memory put
together in a clever way
and you know
it's years of effort to try to do that
right and quite amazing
are there more questions I I don't know
sorry there's another question
could just talk a little bit about the
memory interfaces and issues in memory
like hbm3
um like the signaling rates bandwidth
versus latency because there is like a
band with latency trade-off right HPM
has higher latency over regular DDR can
you maybe talk a little bit about like
what the memory surface looks like from
your perspective and what about the
challenge when it comes when it comes to
the workloads that we're dealing with
um and how we architect our gpus
um and and and our systems and how
they're programmed and how we deal with
parallelism
um uh we're not like a like a regular
CPU or memory latency is King latency is
not King it's on it's it's it's a much
lower concern we don't waste it
but our main concern is efficient
bandwidth an efficiency from a you know
just a utilization perspective then we
make sure that we can fully utilize
whatever bandwidth is given to us and
also from a power perspective
so one thing about hbm is it kind of
does both of those it it has the you
know the total sort of balance that you
want and has the more power efficiency
than any regular DDR so so at least
these types of systems it's a win-win
now you can say that it's also a lot
more expensive so hey you know what it
is but again you have to look at the
total cost of ownership right and all
the parts not just it is is that if you
can get a lot more performance
uh out of a more expensive memory
subsystem
um it can actually be a win for that
ones because it's making all your other
stuff that you're doing to support the
whole system uh more efficient because
your node is more efficient more
performant so it's kind of a funny
little trade-off there you're thinking
about oh I'm buying a you know a
graphics card for my gaming card for my
my my desktop
um you know HPM is too expensive and
everything's the cost of there but when
it comes and and the cost of the car
itself is pretty high when it comes to
the cost of of the of the system itself
um
um it it is is not a big a factor and
performance is a bigger Factor power is
a bigger Factor
yeah I think it makes a lot of sense
um I guess in the one sort of uh we
follow up those touches on this uh issue
is and so you showed some really
impressive numbers for llms
um and I'm sort of wondering you know
what kind of
um
flop utilization do you see right
um on those llms
like given the HPM bandwidth do you have
so you got five banks right so that's a
lot yeah
and so but like can those things feed
the uh can they feed the the GPU fast
enough
yes
yes uh and you know you know I can't
give you the actual specific numbers but
but you know there are multiple layers
and they're different levels of
efficiency you know so it's not like all
100 some things are running highs and
things are running you know more
mid-range and certain efficiency overall
the utilization is is pretty good
um and uh I think from a system I think
maybe asking a system balance
perspective you know the flops and and
and the hbm is the right is the balance
good
um it's a pretty good balance and part
of part of the balance is that we went
from one generation to the next we
didn't just
you know scale everything equally right
we actually made this the system so it's
more efficient right one obvious example
of that is going from fp16 to fb8 right
that that having a smaller data form it
makes the memory system more efficient
um and and you know you can get twice as
much data in the same amount of that one
um that's the common obviously for
example uh but you know just making sure
that we schedule and manage our data
movement and and and and consumption in
a way that can efficiently use and not
waste uh or or or when you don't need to
use the HPM memory you don't have to
cool thing this is a wonderful talk lots
of fantastic details thank you very much
okay uh I hope you can hear me well so I
wanted to ask about AI ecosystem support
so about the media's collaborations
partnership or initiative to support AI
Community
like developer programs AI research
grants do have anything that also would
benefit the future GPU developments
because I see that it also gets in
focused on AI program so I would like to
know more about this
uh yeah I'm probably not the right
person to ask I know we do have a lot of
initiatives and and you know I see you
know in my email that we have Source
summaries of things are happening I see
new initiatives every day
um so I'm not on the on the software
side or the software stack side or the
the kind of the sports side so
um you know uh I'm probably not the
right person to ask that question
um but I do know that that we do you
know have a pretty large sort of support
and a lot of initiatives uh to to help
people use and develop on our gpus and
our systems
thank you sorry I can't help you move
more detail
anyone else
okay well Jack thank you so much it was
a it was an outstanding talk exactly
what I was hoping would you would do so
I can't I can't I can't thank you enough
and uh appreciate taking the time to
tell us about the h100 and uh now all I
want to do is find out how to get one
for my own use
it's a gorgeous machine actually
and um
uh well
well I suspect difficult to use
in a systems context because it has so
many knobs to turn and so much local
optimization that you can make an
enormous amount of improvement by doing
things very carefully
well you know I think the access to and
again I'm not familiar with the details
but you know a lot of these are being
deployed in the cloud and and you know
there should be sort of cloud access to
it through various uh uh
um Avenues
um so you know if you want to kind of
use it as a kind of General uh deep
learning user or HPC user
um probably people more interested about
AI deep learning
um that that that it should you should
be able to get access to that as far as
buying one of your own
um I I don't think you know that's you
know I don't I don't know your financial
situation and what you what kind of you
know data centers setup you have in your
in your basement but um you know that's
that's a bit more
a little more little more Mike Jackson
is my guess is that it takes a it takes
a uh a um a village to make enough money
to pay for one of these things as in his
individual Standalone unit and that's
why we have cloud computing
but it is uh it's a gorgeous piece of
gear now I will say that you know a lot
of our you know things that you run
um and can run and and Frameworks you
can run on on these big large systems
um now they also can run on you know the
the gaming gpus that you that you buy at
Pride well prize is dead but at Best Buy
um but you know no so so if you want to
experiment at a very small scale
um and play around with a very small
scale that is definitely you know
available to you
baby people who will be surplusing the
c100s and as a uh or an a100 rather is a
lower cost to uh home computer
I don't know but this is this is a
because of the the enormous factor of
improvement and just an amazing uh
that's an amazing game
and it's almost all entirely
architectural it seems
well you get some gain from the location
of the process you know there's more SMS
and things like that
um but yeah there's a lot of
architectural improvements uh as well
and and I'll say the last system level
improvements that you can say as well
DMV link the melanox switches and stuff
like that so
um you know it's not just you know the
GPU from a system level perspective it's
a system level architecture that we need
to to in order to get these gains it has
to be a system level uh design
okay well thank you very much again and
I guess with that we'll close for the uh
for the quarter
all right thank you much all right well
thanks goodbye thanks